hello everybody and welcome to part 19
of let's play from dust all right we are
on the last level here you have the
ability to create totems press spacebar
on the emerged earth create a totem oh
okay all right breath of Earth populate
dad Oh get it own oh yeah okay four guys
one girl yeah seems like a good ratio
nice sausage fest going on there okay
and bang yo drums get out here okay oh
I'm pretty sure that something's
horrible gonna have something horrible
is gonna happen on this island I know it
because if the last level was that tough
you have earned the new power breath of
Earth once activated you can sculpt the
earth activate the additional effects of
this often powers with left shift or
exo-k
duniya knee doc doon bucket bucket itas
liu bang your rang okay
or something that me oh oh hello okay I
like it this shift left shift all right
what the Oh whoo oh [ __ ] oh sorry guys
sorry sorry sorry about that you're okay
you're all okay an ex does I guess a
little verse I am oh yeah okay I like
this okay cool finally now it's finally
like a real sandbox game owners is my
like my reward
oh no no no no no no damn it damn it
damn it
of course ah it takes me two minutes
into the game I destroy my village
that's exactly how it goes ah fine fine
fine fine fine okay okay all right
what's next
come on populate it get on with it sorry
guys sorry I'm terrible at my job okay
we up someone just died don't know why
ok just making LAN not gonna spill water
everywhere ok maybe a nice Mountain here
yeah ok there we go
awesome do that look at that
it's cool okay worth more earthly earth
yeah your water get out of here water no
do not seriously what is it with me and
destroying my villages the tiniest
idiots bit of water and they just die
they fall over and die and that is
annoying
okay let's create another totem there we
go that's that yeah that's where I
wanted it a nephew
I wanted that at the top of the mountain
but sure whatever fine you know what I'm
gonna create the top it on right there
oh yeah boom banging I own this place
yeah okay get more couple mounds here
boom oh yeah I'm here - oh come on
another one
boom come on give me another one boom
there we go
all right just gonna bang out these
tones as quick as I can I don't know
where the threat is cuz I know there's a
threat probably probably gonna be a
threat oh don't don't even try it wave
don't even try it get out of here get
out of here that's what I thought get
out of here
all right okay
man this water is a problem I don't know
why water is more against me that lava
is I swear oh and my next power is
breath of lava huh that's gonna be
dangerous I know it I know it I'm gonna
kill some people with that
okay breath of lava let's try it out way
out here Oppie daca pipo ha nothing
boom oh yeah alright
oh now are we doing Oh lava lava lava
lava lava x2
I don't know what X does
oh it makes it go down come on give me
lava come on
I didn't be loving there we go
that's more like it and then kaboom okay
all right that's enough make another one
go populate that well I play with the
Nava and that doesn't last long it just
goes away real quick yeah I got that
cool though on-demand volcanoes I like
that okay let's get rid of that power I
want that power on select I accidentally
set off a volcano right in the middle
the island because that would be bad its
powers breath of the water okay I'm
starting to see the picture here
this would have been useful a long time
ago okay I'm on now get it on go man go
go ladies oh yeah all right
I really wonder why they all wear those
masks
I mean besides the whole tribal thing
there must be some purpose to it fry in
the stories okay one more okay you've
told him right there breath of plants
all right go populate it
okay breath of water see what that does
sploosh as expected get rid of water add
water let's do oh oh no no no no oh go
away go away X X X X damn it now why are
you even bigger no oh why why do I
destroy everything I touch
oh I barely touched it ah why is that
why did you give me that power oh no no
no oh damn it okay um I'll do why oh why
ah why the biggest tidal wave in the
entire game I've ever seen I oh god I
gotta save it okay just raise it up
raise it up raise it up raise it up
raise up raise it up raise it up raise
it up higher higher god that is all that
is wrong why is that wall of water so
damn big it covered everything I barely
touched it I barely I barely touched it
I barely touched it was the worst that
is the worst power ever why did they
give that to me why oh that wasn't even
my fault
that was not my fault not my fault I am
I am a destroyer of worlds
I did not mean for that to happen that
was wrong on so many levels why why must
these people be tormented so with these
unpredictable powers alright moving on
we see if I get rid of this volcano
that's gonna destroy the next place and
get out
looking subside no don't go bigger got
bigger subside I do not want to
volcanoes now let's go away
there you go okay that went away now you
go away X X finally oh man
horrifying I get rid of that power get
rid of all powers I'm not touching any
of the other powers now even breath of
plants I don't trust that probably going
to strangulate everyone with plants the
lines are gonna come out and just kill
everyone that's how this is these things
work no uh get people over here go man
go
go lady go now don't be caught up in a
false sense of security because death
awaits around every single corner lady
all right man I feel bad
all these weirdo monster things again
oh the trip to phobia monsters black
yeah all right almost got everything oh
I so do not trust anything anymore
nothing I trust nothing you just build a
mountain out here
I'm almost at a hundred percent
vegetation so I might as well just
create more land to get a tap okay
breath of plants I do not trust you
breath of plants just build plants and
do nothing else
what is shift you okay there we go just
leave it at that
use them wisely okay get out of here
okay
was it X dude just get rid of the plants
are we okay shift
get them off make them grow okay all
right just be predictable that's all I
ask
that's all I've ever asked okay okay you
have all the powers to make the world in
your image use them wisely
okay maybe nothing bad is gonna happen
maybe I'm finally just at sandbox mode
you know just me playing in a sandbox
hey yeah I'm a little kid playing same
believe me oh yeah all right
is that it that was at the end of the
game maybe my brother was just trolling
me when he said you know be prepared for
the end this doesn't look so bad um yeah
doesn't look bad at all all right
well I guess if this is the end I'm not
gonna make you watch me just play in the
sandbox all day I know better than that
I know that you guys want me to get back
into the horror of things so don't worry
about that
I know I know I know that this game
didn't appeal to all of you a lot of you
guys subscribe to my channel just uh
just so that um you can see me scream
like a little girl in front of all the
horror games stuff like that and I know
that I know that too music so I really
am grateful that you bear with me
through these other games because not
that these aren't exciting a lot of
people a lot of you do like these games
that I didn't read your comments I do
read all the comments by the way I've
read every single comment that's ever
posted every single time I get an email
update I read your comics and comments
in them I'm really grateful that you
guys like my stuff so much and I laugh
when you call me an idiot because I am
an idiot sometimes that I do things
terribly but every for every subscriber
I have for every like I've have for
every um comment I have I really am
grateful that you guys are here for me
I'm gonna keep doing this for you guys
if you like what you see I'm gonna keep
going in don't worry I have more scary
stuff coming for you I'm going to start
doing amnesia custom stories because
some of those probably are very
deserving and I will give you the
screams you are looking for and well it
looks like looks like that's the end of
the game I mean wow I don't see you
anything else to do I've got a hundred
percent vegetation I've got all the
powers I've got all the totems yeah I
think that's it so once again thank you
guys so much for watching
oh whoa whoa hey see one get that one
buddy okay I was premature on that one
okay it's not over see Wow
ah got you at last
okay all right okay Wow okay I'm
actually gonna hold off on that I'm
gonna save it for a final part 20 is
gonna be the final part but what I said
I meant every word of it I really am
grateful for everything that you guys
have given me and it may not seem like
you've given me a lot but in two weeks
in just two weeks I've gotten 750
subscribers from coming from nothing two
weeks ago I had zero subscribers not not
a one but I put out videos and then I
put out that compilation and people just
latched on to it so I'm taking aback by
everything that's happened so I'm
dedicated to this I'm moving forward
with this so thank you guys so much and
I will see you in part 20 of let's play
from dust bye bye